I'm Ernst von weizsäcker I used to be a
professor of biology at present I'm also
co-chair of a United Nations panel
called the international panel for
sustainable resource management
essentially it means that our
grandchildren and grant grant grant
great-grandchildren should also enjoy a
good environment healthy circumstances
and good business
I think that with the coming up of the
climate debate people begin to know that
something like a massive sea level rise
would be called unsustainable it would
mean that vast areas that the coasts
would be drowned and so taking care of
carbon footprints reducing them has
become a much more important agenda
inside the corporate social
responsibility and the sustainability
considerations before it was more on
local pollution health questions which
still are important but now it's more
the global picture at the long-term
let me say the densely populated
countries of the world such as the
Netherlands Denmark Germany Japan South
Korea also China Bangladesh they are
very much concerned with limited
resources to them using resources means
importing resources this is not the case
for Australia or for Canada and to a
very limited agree to the United States
because they are so rich in resources I
believe this makes the deciding
difference between these two groups of
countries but as climate comes in also
Americans with the help of a gore and
others are becoming much more conscious
of what they're doing and what they
shouldn't be doing I suggest that the
Europeans and the East Asians will just
have to go ahead with the technological
transition into resource efficient and
climate friendly technologies until
American companies think oh this is
dangerous they may be running away and
maybe it is better for us in America
that the Congress adopts strict
standards for resource efficiency and
indeed climate-friendly operations
typically the indie anglo-saxon mindset
that is hardly any rule for the
government you think the markets will do
all and if there's scarcity of resources
markets will react but this is wrong
because climate disasters happening
perhaps 50 years from now are not
visible on today's markets so you have
to have a state intervention or an
international agreement like the Kyoto
agreement making it more profitable for
companies to be climate-friendly then to
squander energy and one measure that we
have been taken in my own country at the
time when I was member of parliament was
the ecological tax reform which led
electricity and petrol prices rise in
small steps for five consecutive years
and at the same time was reducing
indirect labor costs and in balance it
was calculated that this saved or
created roughly 300,000 jobs for a small
country like Germany this is a lot
because labor getting cheaper meant that
for the employer it became more
profitable to lay off kilowatt hours and
hire people than the other way around so
this is a policy measure which worked
very well it was not exactly popular but
it was very good for the economy of
Germany and I suggest that America could
emulate that scheme but today it would
be so unpopular that I doubt it was
going it will be adopted it soon
we can do five times better and that
relates to carbon efficiency but also to
metals water and energy in general so
what we are doing considering is a
transport system that is based on very
efficient cars my friend Amory Lovins
talks about the hypercar or revolution
that would do something like hunted in
20 or 150 miles a gallon plus much
better public transport as we have it in
Japan or in most of Europe plus
technological advances in rapid public
transport again in France in Japan in
Germany we have those fabulous trains
which do roughly 250 kilometers per hour
and for practical purposes tend to be
faster than air transport because you
don't have those terrible waiting times
and security checks and all the rest so
that is the transport sector it also
relates of course to goods transport
walmart for instance is renewing their
fleet of lorries of trucks to be more
carbon efficient so it's a multitude of
factors in this one sector of transport
you could also look at agriculture where
water efficiency is perhaps the most
important part drip irrigation and all
the rest but also energy plays a big
role and non-carbon greenhouse gases
play a big role in agriculture or the
housing sector my family and I are
living in a so called passive house
which is roughly 10 times more energy
efficient than conventional homes are
so we are saving a lot of energy have a
very good air quality and at the same
time do something for posterity for a
better climate
I think a very important part answering
discussion is think long term think of
your children think of your
grandchildren and don't be content with
just the quarterly reports their returns
on investment in a very short period of
time this is not sustainable when if I
was a forest owner and wanted to
maximize my next quarterly reports I
would cut cut all the forest and the
trees would be gone and the next quarter
would be a disaster and so would be the
next 50 years so the philosophy the
doctrine of the quarterly reports can be
very damaging and returning to the
question of what makes people move it's
not only the profit thinking it's also a
mentality of thinking we want to have an
elegant kind of life not a wasteful
squandering kind of life it's also into
the aesthetics what do we find beautiful
so I believe it's a mixture of
responsibility good rules and cultural
understanding into a sustainable society
that is indeed quite a difference
between just ownership and use of the
goods i own and services for instance my
family is part of a car sharing
arrangement whenever we need a car we
get it at a relatively low price and we
don't have the permanent costs for for
the car but we always have access to car
like mobility but if for instance my
daughter's family they don't own any car
and they use cars only when they really
need it and otherwise use bicycles and
walking and I don't know what telephones
but we are then living in a privileged
small town of 25 thousand inhabitants in
Germany so there it's easier but even in
New York with public transport you can
do a lot of things without a car but
with the possibility of having access to
a car that I believe is one example the
same holes in a sense for big copying
machines which typically arlys not
bought that's fine and I can imagine
this principle going further for
instance I could imagine that aluminium
will not be sold any longer in the
future but pleased and returned after
use so for instance the air the airplane
manufacturers could rent the aluminium
they need and when the lifetime of the
airplane is over it will be returned and
then of course they all have a strong
interest in doing the optimal optimal
mix
alloys of the metal so that the reuse is
without any problem so access to
aluminium is a very good thing but this
does not automatically mean ownership
why do I need to own aluminum
a balance and as long as a short term
understanding of the philosophy of the
Harvard Business School is ruling all
world it is not sustainable but the
efficiency aspects inside the logic of
the Harvard Business School will stay
but given rules making it more
profitable to think long term to plan
long-term together with the efficiency
ideas of the anglo-saxon economic model
that will create the healthy balance and
I trust that the anglo-saxon countries
will move in the direction of a good
strong state and countries like China or
Egypt of others that have been very
state centered move a more to the center
by allowing more market efficiency
aspects so I'm not saying the
anglo-saxon mentality or business model
is going out but will be better balanced
there was a bit of a catch-22 the United
States of America since the days before
the Kyoto Protocol of nineteen
ninety-seven have a firm political
decision a unanimous decision at Senate
level that they are not going to enter
commitments and lesson until the large
developing countries also do but the
developing countries on their part say
before Kyoto and before Copenhagen we
are not going to enter commitments until
the rich countries have done their
homework so it was sort of clear from
the beginning that the conference would
not lead to binding commitments a
president obama made a clever move by
inviting the big in the developing
countries into some kind of a green room
with the Europeans cut out agreeing on
the so-called Copenhagen Accord which at
least defines that the two degrees
celsius limit should be respected that
soon we should have a peaking of carbon
dioxide emissions and that the nations
including the developing nations should
make at least relative commitments
meaning a reduction of carbon intensity
of their economies which did chinese
we're in the process of doing anyway
which was a good thing the trouble is
that this is less binding then the Kyoto
Protocol and could even kill the Kyoto
Protocol and then the world would would
be without any binding agreement and
this is why many environmentalists and
certainly most of the Europeans said
Copenhagen
failure from the US American perspective
it was not it was perhaps the only way
the American president could come home
with something in his hand tangible
things but I suggest that if all
delegations assembled in Copenhagen had
understood the message a factor five
that you can become richer while at the
same time reducing your carbon emissions
then I believe the attitudes of
Americans Europeans and indeed Chinese
and Indians what would have been
completely different but so far the idea
the ideology if you wish has been that
you get richer only by emitting more
carbon dioxide
we are suggesting to learn from the
glorious experience of the Industrial
Revolution which was the following
between 1850 and say 2150 years or so
the labor productivity has been
increasing year by year by year by year
ending up a 20-fold increase of labor
productivity which is fantastic but the
trick is it always went in parallel with
gross wages with labor costs and this
was a mutual chain of causes if lavaca
gets more expensive companies have a
strong incentive of labor
rationalization of increasing labor
productivity if labor productivity goes
up the trade unions see the potential
for increasing wages so it's a mutually
supportive process this has been a
glorious experience as I said but in
resources which today is actually more
important than labor we have seen a
constant decline of costs the relative
costs measured by the purchasing power
of whatever of a ton of Steel was much
higher 200 years ago than it is now or
hundred years ago at the same
essentially hold for energy so now we
have to engineer this kind of mutual
climbing
says between prices of resources and
resource productivity so it is not just
plainly an energy tax or resource tax it
is an instrument of letting resource
prices rise in parallel step by step
with resource productivity then by
definition there would be no social
hardship the mile driven would not be
more expensive next year even if the
petrol was becoming more expensive
because the driving efficiency would the
fuel efficiency was going up and if this
sort of eternal ecological tax reform
was politically decided you would see
investors engineers managers traders and
indeed consumers flocking into ever more
efficient resource efficient
technologies the selling of LED lamps in
the place of the old incandescent light
bulbs would be sort of a natural thing
to do and all the electrics companies
would run into this direction and
improving it ever further and the same
for the car company is the same for the
infrastructure planners for public
transport in agriculture organic food
would become much more competitive
compared with energy intensive and
pesticide intensive food and the entire
economy from buildings through mobility
agriculture heavy industry and
everything all sectors would move into
the direction of what we call a new
Kondratiev cycle a new long-term cycle
of technology in this time characterized
by maybe a five-fold increase of
resource productivity with the width the
constant whip
of gradually increasing resource prices
I think that after the bad experience of
Copenhagen the Cancun meeting will at
least try and find a new compromise one
element that I find particularly
important is unlikely to be on the
agenda but maybe in a post Mexico
conference this is per capita equal
emission rights that means an American a
German a Russian the Japanese has no
larger right to make use of the
atmosphere then a person from Cameroon
Bangladesh China Ecuador or whether
whatever a developing country and that
would mean for us in the North with very
high per capita emissions we would have
to go shopping to India to Bangladesh
buying rights if that was politically
agreed with or without America you would
see investors in India in China and
Brazil and other places when considering
the construction of a new coal power
plant to weigh it against the potential
of selling permits to the rich countries
today planning at building a new coal
power plant for electricity in India or
in China is a license for printing money
it's so fabulously profitable but as
soon as selling and carbon dioxide
permits to America to Germany and other
places becomes an alternative it becomes
very profitable then
all of a sudden the Chinese and the
Indians would say look we also have
fantastic opportunities of becoming more
energy-efficient needing much less
electricity and in stead becoming rich
by selling permits so this would be
something which Cancun should address
and later conferences should agree on
there is indeed the notion of the
historical debt we have built up all
this global warming that is out there
the Indians and many other in developing
countries in Copenhagen it was chiefly
Sudan as the speaker of the g77 talked
about the historical debt I believe
there is some truth in it and in a sense
President Obama reacted to it by saying
we in the rich highly industrialized
countries should come up with some money
the idea was about a hundred billion
dollars or so to give to developing
countries to facilitate and accelerate
they're becoming more carbon efficient
that would be one way of unloading our
historical debt
in the case of ordinary buildings in
Germany we have that wonderful example
of dr. Wolfgang Feist now moving from
new buildings for passive houses into
refurbishing old houses large stretches
of apartment houses in our inner cities
or so and again like in new buildings he
has been able to prove that something
like an eighty-five percent improvement
of energy efficiency is available now
and I believe capital destruction is
always a bad option it's better to build
on existing structures infrastructures
buildings and all the rest and that
makes it much more feasible politically
for countries like the US or Germany to
switch to a new direction so the shrimp
a Tyrian idea of creative destruction i
believe is misleading concept
it is a fact that the terrible tragedy
of the Katrina hurricane destroying much
of New Orleans has created a lot of
awareness in America on the dangers of
climate change and if an increase of
heavy storm events leads to more
awareness building in the United States
but also in tropical countries of course
then the chances for getting not so
popular policies through Congress or
through the respective Parliament's
worldwide are greatly improving but one
should not fall into the illusion of
quick battle wins if we move into the
right direction it may still take 20
even 50 years until good results can be
measured but this is not an argument
against doing it because if we continue
hesitating then the price will be much
higher the damage will be will be much
bigger this is the reasoning of lord
stern in the stern review and later of
saying the longer we wait the more
expensive will the transition be so we
better act now
some way by deciding 10 years ago of the
introduction of the common currency the
euro Germany has made a commitment of
bailing out be it indirectly through the
International Monetary Fund or more
directly through the european bank but I
once calculated the amount of the Greek
deficit compared with the gross national
product of Europe and this is less than
half a percent so I would call it
alarmist to say this half percent of the
European of the eurozone GDP lets the
euro collapse this is absurd if you
compare that with financial risks
incurred by the American state in
certain war adventures or in the
financial crises or wherever those are
much higher percentages leading indeed
to a weak dollar that's that's correct
but the European industry is only happy
if the overvaluing of the euro finally
finds it in so I'm not in a state of
alarm
they certainly will recover them and
they exist since two thousand years and
they have a very strong message but they
don't deserve to recover soon unless
they really accept the guilt that some
individuals loaded on themselves and the
institution has to learn that perhaps
the conditions under which priests work
are conducive to certain misbehavior so
maybe the conditions will have to be
changed this has been the case in the
so-called Reformation by Martin Luther
and others at that time the Catholic
Church was in a much worse state of
affairs much with much more guilt in
that sense than today and it has kind of
led to a purification the challenge from
the reformate from the Reformation has
led the Catholics to learn much from
Luther and others so now they are almost
indistinguishable